So we still tell ourselves,
we still believe that in
a marketplace of ideas
that good true content
is gonna rise to the top.
But the interesting thing
about social platforms
is that the algorithms are designed
to amplify what's popular.
So if you can game the algorithm
and get something trending
we have these curatorial
services like Search,
Trending, and the Recommendation Engine
which don't fulfill the same
function as human editors
because for better or worse
human editors are biased,
but algorithms they're
biased and game-able.
And so we have this interesting
environment we've created
where the assumptions that have
kinda under-lied our beliefs
and how good content and
messaging rises to top,
the sort of notion of Brandeis and Mill,
that bad speech will overcome good speech,
is really largely defunct
in the era of automated bots
and the ability for anyone
to go and spam a hashtag
and spread a message
regardless of voracity.
We're at the point where
if you make it trend
you make it true,
because some journalist somewhere
is going to cover the fact
that it was trending.
And there's an insidiousness to this,
because as we've entered into this world
of information glut,
people are really at a loss
as to what to trust what sources are good.
And so people become in
many ways, very reliant
on the sort of circle of
people who are nearest to them
and what those people happen to share.
And this is why one of the challenges
is where human biases intersect
with technological mechanisms.
There's comfort in seeing things
that reflect your world view.
And so, when someone
shares content that is
completely false or biased or misleading,
the Facebook algorithm
recognizes that this is a share
from a trusted friend,
and so it does in fact spread
it to the rest of your feed.
So if you go in and look at truther pages,
you see these kind of
classic tactics that play,
you make a new visitor
feel a sense of belonging,
you reinforce their world view,
you congratulate them on being awake,
they're welcomed into a group.
And we kind a joke around about the fact
that social networks
have disrupted the market
for cult leaders.
(audience laughs)
And that's because
propagandists need an audience.
It doesn't matter how
they get the audience,
the only thing that matters
is that the audience exists.
And so on social
networks, you can buy one,
you can build one, or you can co-oped one.
So there's a lot of different ways
that you can run this playbook.
Maybe you start with ads,
maybe you buy some ads
and the call to action on
the ad is to like a page.
And then I have you on my
page, you've all liked my page
that means that Facebook
is gonna push you at least
some of the things that
I share on the page.
And in fact, I can tell
you to tweak a setting
that make sure that my page
is the first thing you see.
And then maybe you're
really active on my page
and you like other people
who comment on my page.
And then Facebook actually suggests
that maybe you and your friends
should create a shared group
to talk about my page.
And then at that point, I
have you in a group also.
And once you're in a
group, that conversation
is largely happening, closed and private
and so is very difficult for
people who do try to monitor
the rise of unfortunate hate
groups and things like that
to really see what's happening
in the closed groups on Facebook.
It sort of has become this space
where we call it the kinda
radicalization engine
as the groups...
Once you're in a certain
number of these groups
Facebook tries to feed you more groups
that are like them, ultimately again,
the goal is to have an audience
and so you can move that audience
from platform to platform
you can use blogs, tracking pixels,
the entire system is set
up such that I can find you
and reach you where you are.
And that's why when people say propaganda
has always existed,
they're absolutely right.
But what has not always existed is
inexpensive, sophisticated,
precision targeting.
Environments where I know
who is likely to be receptive
to my message, so I can build my audience
remarkably inexpensively
and remarkably efficiently,
precisely because the
Facebook ads interface
will serve my message to the
person who needs to see it
for relatively small sums of money.